hello and a warm welcome to world
stories im sue me so Miss Conda with
your international reporters magazine
thanks for joining us on this week's
edition will introduce you to an
inspiring female journalist who's
breaking barriers in Liberia we learn
about growing health concerns in Qatar
and we raise our pom-poms to Bulgaria
spritely golden girls all that more but
first we start with a report from Brazil
where a strong entrepreneurial spirit
has helped bolster economic growth in
recent years rather than taking on the
risk and responsibility of starting a
new company completely from scratch many
Brazilians are opting for another
business plan franchising in fact it's
now become one of the country's most
successful models and as Simona po4
ready- TV shows us it works for products
and services everything from Middle
Eastern fast food to car rentals
Habib's took on large multinational
companies to win a place for itself
among Brazil's fast food franchises the
business concept was a bold one to serve
inexpensive quickly prepared Middle
Eastern cuisine to Latin Americans the
first franchise opened in 1992 the
initial goal was 50 locations that since
expanded to 410 a huge orjinal the
company still owns about forty percent
of the restaurants the other sixty
percent of franchises rob is acceptable
salt water screwdrivers Brazil's very
business friendly legislation encourages
entrepreneurs to keep expanding their
businesses some ninety-seven percent of
the country's franchise operations are
Brazilian origin afriqiyah brasilera le
muito profissional azada a franchising
in brazil is very professional at the
aspectos needy and the suits are
Brazilian DNA just wonderfully that's
you Elmo sue our tropical character and
our economic social and enterprising
qualities yeah so CIC empresarios
the car rental company locally Jie has
over 500 branches in 9 countries with a
total fleet of around 100,000 vehicles
that puts the company among the world's
6 biggest car rental companies it's been
active abroad longer than any other
Brazilian company
we're by far he'll be the first
international branch in Argentina
followed by uruguay and paraguay in
1992-93 we set out to conquer the MacOS
or the southern common market for food
wait about moon some window stand
disorder a lot of financial investment
and the difficulty of finding well
trained workers that's the climate that
makes the mini franchise business model
so attractive it's shown amazing growth
the past few years sit out there you can
start a mini franchise for just sixteen
thousand euros fabulous seventeen
percent of Brazilian companies are many
franchise operations these small
businesses are mainly active in the
service sector dr. resolver is a
franchise company specializing in
remodeling and repairs according to the
Brazilian franchising association in
2011 this company set up more franchises
than any other firm in Brazil a total of
three hundred and two one such location
is near the city of better reason che
it's managed by Leila de Freitas a young
public relations student
I'm curious how old are you I'm 21 me
too and why did you decide to join this
company is never watch a mere family
same thing we always wanted to run our
own business to take on the
responsibility so my father and brother
took a look around the market and they
decided that this would be worth
investing in Yuma Frankia obras you the
mostest ill despise demise Brazil is one
of the most high professional countries
when it comes to franchising yeah what
could you and I believe that the
Brazilian entrepreneurial spirit is
acting is a good example for this sector
and other countries as well don't you
finish this chanequa giochi Julie
Brazilians enjoy doing business castanos
cheap reindeer estamos busca la voz de
goes did he say we're always looking for
new ideas and trying to grow and develop
oh no Meah G hetro alimenta so yo you
sooo identify Tendo ah la purissima
jamarcus that galvanizes the national
economy and leads to creating new
markets with ever stronger concepts
better held in high regard and are based
on the franchise model he seems like was
we turn our attention now to cut our a
place often associated with wealth and
luxury Qatar is indeed one of the
richest states in the Gulf region but
with that prosperity has come the
trappings of modern Western societies
including fast food and sugary drinks in
Qatar that's taken a bite out of
traditional healthier eating habits the
small Arab state now has one of the
highest obesity rates in the world and
that's led to a sharp increase in
diabetes Mary Ferrara from un TV has
more on the Gulf nations sweet epidemic
Qatar's bounty of wealth has transformed
the lives of many from a nomadic
lifestyle to one of luxury and leisure
but this shift in lifestyle has come at
a significant price one that's affecting
the health of some two hundred and
fifteen thousand people double command
can win this burner i want ceraadi my
favorite i used to be able to walk to
the car without any difficulty now i
have to use a wheelchair that callous
al-assad that the whole of a sarah abdul
razak was 25 years old when he was
diagnosed with diabetes a condition in
which there are high levels of sugar in
the blood known is the silent killer a
staggering twenty percent of the
nation's population is living with the
disease manal musallam is a doctor at
qatar largest medical institution hamad
medical corporation i can say there is
no any familiar without diabetic patient
and cutter according to the world health
organization nearly 350 million people
worldwide almost five percent of the
world's population and living with the
disease it's estimated that this number
could double within the next 20 years
experts blame the rise partially on
genetics but sedentary lifestyles and
skyrocketing obesity rates also
contribute to the problem further the
foods in Gulf area I was only mostly
rice and meat now there is so many
variety of the foods fast food chains
now dot the landscape across the Gulf
region the people die like a junk food
once a talented sportsman at 52 Abdul
Razak is now confined to his home
leaving only to go to the hospital for
frequent medical checks and treatment
he's also relegated to a lifetime of
prescription medications injections and
constant monitoring of his blood sugar
levels despite his compliance the
disease is rapidly claiming different
parts of his body home over there
Michelle colada Philip I can't see with
my left eye hollyann hollows now his
kidneys are failing Abdul Razak relies
on his son to take him to the hospital
three times a week his physician dr.
adel siobhan says dialysis is keeping
him alive I think his health improved
significantly since he started dialysis
alarmed by the rapid spread of the
disease the Qatari government is working
with international partners to find a
cure and through genetic analysis it
hopes to determine a person's likelihood
of developing the disease and while
there is hope for the future for now
abdul razzaq is on a waiting list for a
kidney transplant without this operation
his chances of survival remains slim now
something old something new something
borrowed something blue that's a
long-standing wedding tradition you may
have heard of before there are things
that brides in some parts of the world
makes sure to have on their special day
for luck and good fortune in Bangladesh
weddings are wildly colorful affairs and
their Hindu Brides can't do without a
pair of bangles made of conch shells
it's a sacred tradition that's been
carried on for generations and there's
an entire industry behind producing the
beautiful accessories psycho outlet on
from etv shows us more
a wedding is a ceremony that joins two
people in marriage and while traditions
and customs may vary between cultures
religions and countries the bride and
groom generally marked the occasion by
celebrating with family and friends
Bengali weddings are especially
elaborate they include many rituals and
ceremonies that can span over several
days one important element of hindu
marriage ceremonies the bride's conch
bangles according to tradition the conch
bangles slipped onto the bride's arms
during the ceremony have the same
significance as a wedding ring worn by
Bridal couples in other cultures in a
village in the Natur addictive
Bangladesh around 100 families have been
earning a living for generations making
these traditional conch bangles
only be able showed a motherboard in
theater Lee I don't know I'm not
carrying on the business passed down to
us by our grandparents and parents I yep
shut up William logically we don't own
any land so this provides us with a
livelihood secondly more than the song
Yama did after lines we get the conch
shells from the corner district Inlet
thought I wanted honking yes we know the
wholesalers there and if we buy in bulk
you'll pre-cut the shells into pieces
for us she then we file and smooth them
once they have the proper shape we clean
and polish them and sell them in the
villages Bowie marabu lumba gram Wanda
to compete very busy the conch shells
from which the bangles are made are
imported from other countries local
entrepreneurs manage the initial
processing the craftsmen procure the
other materials from various parts of
the country hill along with elongata we
import our conch cells from Sri Lanka by
the way of chittagong we have cutting
machines in our homes I'm a wholesaler I
cut the large shells into slices and
then sell them in North Bengal the
people who work in this industry are
referred to as shankari the work begins
early and is shared by nearly all the
men and women in the village some are
responsible for washing the rough cut
pieces others polish them with special
chemicals and conch dust later they may
be engraved with delicate patterns
before receiving a final finish rockshox
love money neither idea tecra have an
example look we open create patterns
ourselves is that identity basically we
think of our own designs what's in that
left idea city but of course that
requires a fair amount of time if we
copy an existing pattern how did you
guess you like one that's been done
before we can usually finish a bangle in
just a half an hour Parvati mine
ethylene put the hot desi da pasando
hashiba vakola
the conch bangles are always made in
pairs and are available in many
different sizes some of the finished
bangles are purchased by small business
owners who then sell them at markets
others are sold door-to-door they're
also exported to countries like India
Sri Lanka Bhutan and Nepal heavily damn
what I would be one bangle can cost
anywhere from fifty to three hundred
fifty taka which is about fifty cents to
three and a half euros some have gold
coatings but those are quite expensive
wealthier people can afford them on
ordinary people what a simpler one Avery
I'm de Xiang kenosha with no politician
yes we get the conscious from Noah para
they're cut into pieces and then
finished by craftsmen and sold in
different districts like Rome poor and
dinajpur the bangles I sell costs
between 50 and 150 taka felony a victory
I'm not solely as long as there are
weddings there will be a livelihood for
the Sun carries of bhagat e para wadding
williams is considered Liberia's most
powerful female journalist she's the
chief editor at a major Liberian news
outlet and she's dedicated her career to
writing about the plight of girls and
women in her native country even though
Liberia has a female president most
women there are faced with extreme
adversity from poverty to poor education
now thanks to what a Williams some of
their struggles have come to light and
now she's received the 2013 German
development media award in recognition
of her work Oliver moyem has more about
the journalist and one of the stories
she shared mercy woman sits under the
burning afternoon Sun next to a mountain
of rock soon as the rock pool she has a
scarf tied around her head to protect
her from the harsh wreath and a hammer
in her hand ready to break rocks
wha de williams reads aloud from the
article that brought her to berlin to
collect the german development media
award women who live at the bottom of
the societal change she's the current
newsroom chief for frontpage Africa in
Monrovia making her the highest placed
female editor in Liberia she specializes
in controversy she's interviewed
fearsome warlords condemned
discrimination against homosexuals and
reported on infibulation or female
genital mutilation to be able to thrive
as a female editor in Liberia as even a
female media practitioner who sort of
higher up in the hierarchy is is really
difficult but I don't know of any other
female editor of a newspaper in Liberia
except ye Williams Williams has made a
way in a traditionally male-dominated
society even braving death threats
Liberia is by no means accustomed to
women standing up for their rights so
aggressively
she does this for women like mercy when
the 18 year old isn't working in the
quarry or taking care of others she goes
to school she wants to graduate from
secondary school pause Morden the Civil
War and her family's grinding poverty
kept her out of school for some years
now Mercy's in 7th grade she told Wadi
Williams that she gets 35 Liberian
dollars or about forty cents per bucket
of rocks on a good day she can fill
seven buckets she's been doing this for
five years now Massey says she uses the
money to pay her school fees she even
has a bit left over for food and
clothing
like so many others merci and her
parents moved to the city in search of
work and driven by the country's near
eighty-five percent unemployment the
city's growing economy promised a better
life
until you get the right people you know
to to to take the courage you know to
tell these stories and expose you know
the else in society the society will
continue to degenerate and we saw what
we had over 10 years we saw the kind of
bloodshed that we had so telling these
stories and when policymakers take
action then you know that you've done
something years of civil war have left
at least a quarter of a million people
dead and more than 1 million displaced
the militias and political party is
fighting for ethnic supremacy and
control of resources drove Liberia to
the brink of ruin
after the election of ellen johnson
sirleaf Africa's first female president
and later Nobel laureate things
gradually started looking up with debt
relief steadily increasing foreign
investment and state revenues but
corruption and joblessness remain women
are especially hard hit mercy is one of
many Liberian women who live at the
bottom of the societal chain despite the
fact that Liberia has a female president
Harold L for promoting women's rights
and welfare life for women is
particularly hard Williams doesn't mince
words in her articles she boldly
criticizes social injustice 'as she
wants to see her country regain its
former strength and has concrete ideas
for change especially for the younger
generation this is precisely why the
jury chose wardi williams for the 2013
german development media awards in the
Africa category
and we should let you know that WOD a
story on mercy sparked reactions around
Liberia and beyond several people have
even offered to help pay for mercy's
education now finally today some proof
that age is merely a number it's
important to stay vital and healthy into
old age and exercise is a key part of
making that happen in our next story we
meet an unusual cheerleading squad made
up of women in their golden years they
found a great way to keep fit socialize
and have fun and they've even made a
name for themselves across their native
Bulgaria chair no more TVs curiel Espada
wolf brings us this story
some five years ago veteran athletes in
Bulgaria's Black Sea port of Varna
started a cheerleading team complete
with pom-poms for women aged 62 85 and
called it the health sports club
what is the aim of the health sports
club what are the girls in their golden
years do in the club the resident know
we have a lot of fun here it's a
meaningful way for us to spend our time
especially when there's nothing else to
fill it no tropic air ad William Dodds a
tuba Jim it also gives us an opportunity
to socialize and do something good for
ourselves and the community is an ass
he's oops just walk to the show 2 News
in addition to the physical benefit we
get we also perform at various sporting
events he's visiting the resistant
noodle p idea we kick off tournaments
and other things with our routines Annja
do give it away but first and foremost
it's great fun to be a grand cheerleader
yeah balls to be good and it's good for
body and soul yeah yes exactly both body
and soul our sports club is named health
because what we do benefits our help
how did you come to this club I mean
would that any I was invited to join by
sashka cueva who I've known for 20 years
I've never regretted it not for a moment
I'm glad good cool what is that first of
all i really enjoy exercising three
times a week that keeps me fit and
secondly thanks to the club my life is
enhanced both socially and culturally i
learn about the events taking place in
Varna each community now thanks to the
club I can participate in them and last
but not least I've made good friends in
the club people I'm glad to know what I
regret about the pain you didn't poem
you I meet the exercise alleviates pain
hello aesthetics and yoga it keeps your
joints fit which is taboo of organismal
do you have advice for others your age
you haven't yet joined the club boobs
the dollar I mean the begin going life
is short hello summation what does your
family think of your hobby nobody very
supportive have you taken part in events
and other Bulgarian towns tradition 50
value for this thing gonna do it I
prekrasno it's great those events give
us an opportunity to visit major
cultural and historical centers around
the country equally 10 through wave of
terrible gaya
the quarter when people think of the
elderly they often imagine a bottle of
water and a pile of pills on the
nightstand what's on your nightstand
emotion there's a bottle of water but
there are no pills okay you still read
books of course I do when do you watch
movies yes I watched movies and read
books here at the club we often discuss
movies talk about the stories and
characters in them I feel alive here I
can participate in life and that's
invigorating to some jasonville revolt
and CEO Steve a parolee unusual at the
regional tournament of clubs for health
and longevity in razgrad Bulgaria 21
teams from Bulgaria's largest cities
took part thanks to their top-notch
performance Varna's team stood out
that's one reason Varna's grand
cheerleaders are asked to open major
sporting events like the third
tournament for the Varna's seniors Cup
organized by chair no TV and
international football tournament and an
annual volleyball tournament at the end
of the year the grand cheerleaders will
be performing at the national
championship in pre Moscow the National
Gymnastics Championships and clevon and
the leaves of memories festival grand
cheerleader is a great way for Golden
Girls to stay active and healthy
well that's all for this edition of
world stories from us our reporters and
partner stations around the world thanks
for watching if you'd like to watch
other episodes head to our website
that's DWD forward slash world stories
will leave you with this week's picks of
the world see you next time with more
world stories
you